[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all right first you flick this switch
then this switch that activates then you
push this button which will give you
five minutes to get out of there now
whatever you do don't push this button
because that will set off the bomb
immediately and we'll all be dead now
repeat back what I just said that's
right the button it won't kill everyone
try again huh how's that even possible
which button is the button you're
supposed to push point to it shut up and
give me some pain
does anybody have any tape out there I
want to put some paper over the death
button the drawer you want to open has
this symbol
what no he thinks she won him to wear it
as a head that's not what I said okay
he's relieved you don't want him to go
he hates heads go on anyone not just
himself oh yeah one minute you think
someone has a weird-shaped head the next
minute just because you realized part of
that head is that hat that's why you
don't like hats this is an important
conversation right now
[Music]
[Music]
adding there
[Music]
baby Groot might be the star of the
entire show we're gonna need to have a
real discussion about your language
legacy effects created the original
sculpt based on artwork created by the
marvel visual development team and once
legacy had created this practical sculpt
that everyone bought off on we then
handed that over to our visual effects
company and said okay start building
this let's see how he moves and how the
internal vines move and how much do you
make his face move the older Groot has a
crusty series of panels of wood that you
can use to articulate but we've now got
a young smooth bark to face so how do
you make a smooth bark face move and
animate so it doesn't look like a big
stretchy piece of rubber baby Groot is
much angrier than adult group and is
hitting Drax every chance he can get one
he hates Drax which is what makes the
moment at the end so sweet when Drax is
the money really wants to go to
[Music]
you've got dave bautista who's like six
three or something and Chris Pratt who
same sort of height B's two big guys and
you're standing next to this little ten
inch tall character and that becomes
photographically certainly a challenge
we would always have a standing 10 inch
maquette that we would put down in the
scene and say this is how he is that
gave me and the cast and everyone else
involved a much greater sense that there
was this little character there on set
all the time ah man what did he do to
you there is something about him that
works in a way where your heart just
melts but he's also a bit of a jerk
that selfish jerky attitude is what
makes him work he is unbelievably
adorable at times but if he just was
unbelievably adorable all the time it
would just get so saccharine we couldn't
handle it because he also does kill
people they was sad and three two one go
[Music]
just who do you think
[Music]
you are a garden of the galaxy guardians
of the galaxy
why would we be the guardians of the
galaxy so stupid the Ravagers the
sovereign
they want to take over the galaxy so we
saving the galaxy again I get hot
[Music]
I see it within you fear betrayal or any
of you do is yell at each other
stupid raccoons star much you're right
we're family
Showtime a hose
[Music]
[Applause]
it's beautiful
Haigh what about this little plant can I
smash it with a rock no it's too
adorable to care
[Music]